le président d'interpol l'emirati ahmed
nacer elle réussit visé par une nouvelle
plainte pour torture elle a été déposée
hier au pôle crimes contre l'humanité du
parquet antiterroriste à paris alors que
le nouveau président se trouverait en
france l'homme déjà visé par deux
plaintes n'a jamais été jugé les détails
avec notre reporter nadège abderrazak
une nouvelle plainte pour torture et
actes de barbarie a été déposée hier au
pôle crimes contre l'humanité du parquet
national anti terroriste contre ahmed
nacer el rhayti qui vient d'être
intronisé président d'interpol l'emirati
a été élu fin novembre à la tête de
l'organisation internationale de
coopération policière et il avait déjà
été à l'époque un visé par deux plaintes
des plaintes classées sans suite pour
absence de compétence l'intéressé ne
résidez pas en france et ne se trouvait
pas non plus sur le sol français
aujourd'hui c'est différent puisqu'il
s'est rendu à lyon ces derniers jours et
lyon où se trouve le siège d'interpol et
c'est d'ailleurs lui même qui l'a fait
savoir sur les réseaux sociaux
en ce début d'année j'entame aujourd'hui
ma première visite à lyon en france en
tant que président d'interpol dans la
tente de travailler avec les membres du
comité exécutif et le secrétaire général
en tant qu'équipe intégré pour une plus
grande sûreté et sécurité mondiale l'une
de ces deux plaintes avaient été
déposées en jouant par l'omg gulf center
for human rights elle présentait
l'opposant ahmed mansour comme détenu à
abou dhabi dans des conditions je cite
moyenâgeuse constitutive d'actes de
torture c'est cette même organisation
qui est de nouveau déposé plainte hier
contre ahmed nacer el aissi lorraine
j'ai exclu d'emblée son éventuelle
immunité liée à sa fonction car le
général émirati exercerait toujours des
fonctions policières abou dhabi
faire procéder à son interpellation
immédiatement est une obligation
impérative de la france aux termes des
conventions internationales qu'elle a
signé
l'autre plainte avait été déposée début
octobre par retenait dixon celle avocat
de deux plaignants britannique on
rapportait en octobre à lyon des faits
de détention arbitraire ou de torture en
2018 et 2019 l'élection d'ali agça à
istanbul le 25 novembre comme président
d'interpol a choqué champ particulier
les défenseurs de droits humains et des
responsables politiques qui estimait
qu'elle portait atteinte à la mission de
l'organisation